We Begin this morning with this top
story the first big test of a new era of
immigration along the U.S Mexico border
tens of thousands of migrants are
seeking Refuge after the pandemic era
border restrictions policy known as
title 42 expired just before midnight on
Thursday the Biden Administration is
battling Court challenges from both
sides of the aisle that claim they could
hamper their ability to handle
historically high levels of border
crossings in the weeks ahead the
unprecedented chaos and surge of
migrants some lawmakers warned about did
not come in the first 24 hours after the
policy officially ended but now there is
a wave of fear and uncertainty along the
southern border Christina raffini
reports from the White House Christina
good morning
good morning as you mentioned border
officials say they didn't see a
significant uptick in the number of
migrants at the border ahead of the
expiration of that law but
Administration officials say they're
doing the best they can with a broken
system and limited resources
at checkpoints along the U.S Mexico
border crowding confusion and
frustration on both sides of the fence
I'm going to cross into the U.S through
the river says Jesus Bravo a 23 year old
from Venezuela after days of trying and
failing to get an online immigration
appointment they never reply he says so
I'll have to cross through the river
like everybody else we have had a plan
uh for more than a year and a half we've
been executing on that plan and we
continue to execute on the plan
appearing on CBS Secretary of Homeland
Security Alejandro mayorquez said about
60 000 migrants gathered at the border
to await the end of title 42. a pandemic
era rule that allowed expulsion of
immigrants who entered the U.S
unlawfully the policy expired one minute
before midnight on Friday we provide
lawful safe and orderly Pathways for
people to come to the United States when
they qualify for relief but that relief
could be harder to act success under a
new Biden Administration rule that
disqualifies most migrants from Gaining
Asylum without first applying for it in
another country those caught Crossing
illegally can face Swift expulsion a
five-year ban and possible criminal
charges the president is using the tools
that he has in front of him to deal with
this issue the White House says Congress
needs to act and reform the broken
immigration system but Republicans
including Florida governor and likely
GOP 2024 presidential candidate Ron
DeSantis are calling for even stricter
rules I mean I would say the the Border
should be shut down
now also this week a 17 year old from
Honduras died at a migrant shelter in
Florida he was found unresponsive taken
to the hospital and later pronounced
dead the Honduran government has asked
for a full investigation and Jeff and
autopsy is underway
Christine in a separate topic here not
the most exciting one but it is pressing
the White House dealing with a debt
limit negotiations where do things stand
there
Jeff lawmakers were actually supposed to
meet here at the White House yesterday
that meeting was pushed till next week
now sources told CBS News that's a good
thing that means staffs are talking and
potentially making progress but
President Biden is scheduled to leave
for Japan on Wednesday giving these two
groups that so far have remained very
far apart a short limited amount of time
to get some sort of an agreement before
the U.S reaches its borrowing limit in
just a few weeks
okay Christina raffini at the White
House thank you very much